speak on the hill
you can't rise if all you do is play
white
i'm so sorry can we go back yep
i thought we were going back further
that's one for the bloopers
[Music]
she
really oh is it like moving i can't just
do it again jesus
can we take that back real quick
that's dude
[Music]
i use my signature spice mix
no offense daddy but
interviews you know cool people
it's so awkward
i don't know how to this is just
i'm sorry it's like there's got to be an
easier way
it just seems like nobody
guys we gotta keep stage doors closed
please
that was my best work
you see vivian the donations have slowed
down so
sorry sloane is not at work yeah yeah
but you pulled it out i heard you say
slow before i was like that's a good
word
i think it is in brooklyn
don't even sweat that [ __ ]
yo just coconut
[Laughter]
i feel like this is like a recap like
we're doing gemini man yeah that's what
it feels like
african-american cuisine is american
cuisine
african-american cuisine is america
[Laughter]
and you're not coming in thinking about
doing a prank on another cast member
we got oh
oh that's nice
[Music]
i'm hillary hillary it's a lovely name
oh beautiful name i don't have to call
you the tall lady in the in the
now
yeah beautiful name i don't know how to
call you
don't be nervous
i hate you
i know that ain't actually swinging
through
hey i'm so sorry
[Music]
yo yo i'm not talking about alexis i'm
talking about excellence everywhere i go
i say yo i need bracelets of where i'm
from where i'm going to
get out my way i need them
don't make me rush
where am i going
[Music]
well good morning
it was a little early
just just just
two seconds i hope you're hungry
actually let's stop because you got some
on your tooth
see i can't that
this is for you
it's from my girl i don't know her name
um her name is phantom this is for you
it's from my homegirl
fancy
this is for you from my homegirl pharma
uh her name is phantom
okay
funny okay beautiful smile
brings harmony
little what
great
[Music]
look at how round that head is probably
like 15. and now i'm growing up i'm big
when you get to the expert level you
won't even have to look at the ball
you you cassie
let's do it one more time
[Music]
is
[Music]
you